my name is Chris Knowlton as you heard
I'm with Wiles and media systems and I
come our company got started actually
when our founders in 2005 thought they
wanted to start a new business and they
weren't really sure which this is not
mine I just want you to realize that
they wanted to get into video they
thought it was emerging it they thought
it'd be really interesting so they
started to a video blogging business and
they found why they were trying to build
out the business that they couldn't find
a media server on the market that met
their needs it was not they couldn't
find one that was scalable reliable and
flexible enough and so as part of the
business they developed their own media
server and then they went out to trade
shows and people kept coming to them and
saying yeah I don't care about the video
blogging but what server are you using
because I want that and so they did a
pivot and they started a new business
around something called
Wiles a media server and so it's been on
the market since it actually went out in
pre-production in 2006 by the time it
launched in February 2007 had a thousand
users on it already
we now have folks in over 150 countries
using it and it's arguably now the most
widely used streaming media server in
the world and oh there we go yeah yeah
that's good and so it's it's used for a
lot of things it's one of the nice
things about it is that it's been in the
market as I mentioned since early 2007
every year it has won multiple awards
both Readers Choice Awards and editors
choice awards for innovation and for
support and and one of the nice things
about it I guess is when it came to
market what it was really competing with
a lot was flash media server Windows
Media Server then is media services and
real networks and eventually all of
those have pretty much either gone away
or changed their focus like Microsoft's
no longer shipping media server software
realnetworks is not and Adobe's focused
on their OTT are their TV Everywhere
offering through primetime and so it we
had we came to the market was something
that's supported multiple protocols
multiple ways of streaming so not just
window
Media word--just is media or real
streaming but combination of all of
those basically - you could take a
single workflow with wowza media server
and replace multiple parallel workflows
that you had with all these other
technologies and some of the other
technologies were obviously based on
using a certain operating system another
thing that wiles it has done is based
the server on that the base its ability
to run not on any single operating
system but I'm multiple so to run on
almost same machine you have so it makes
it very flexible it's made it very
attractive to a lot of folks it was
originally aimed at developers and folks
who were streaming media professionals
and over time what we've tried to do is
continue to simplify streaming not only
by offering multiple formats in a single
product and the ability to ingest from
almost any encoder and deliver to almost
any screen on the planet but to do it in
a simpler way and to make it easier and
easier lowering the bar to get involved
in streaming and not having to be so
technically literate to get started so
let's see what did I miss anything we're
growing fast lots of awards ok good move
on so this is for those of you who might
have heard of wowza media server
originally it's now actually called
Wow's the streaming engine we changed
the name last year and we released a
user interface for it before then it was
all about XML and command-line which is
great for a lot of you for a lot of
folks it was a little bit intimidating
so we put a nice wrapper around it
web-based UI so that even from your your
your Android phone your tablet your
desktop wherever you are you can control
your server just by going into a web
browser to a URL let's see did I miss
anything it's I did mention the multiple
formats the idea that you can stream in
multiple formats not just a single one
you can do smooth streaming you can do
HTTP dynamic streaming Adobe's adaptive
streaming format or as well as rtmp and
RTSP how many of you how many here
actually know what I'm talking about
when I mention these acronyms okay a few
of you excellent let me let me just put
it this way no matter what device you
have an iPhone and Android a windows
phone a television
top box Wow's the streaming engine can
put out a stream in a format that those
devices will be able to playback from so
you no longer have to have multiple sets
of technologies to hit all those
endpoints so who uses well as it is a
question I get asked usually the
question I asked back is who doesn't use
Wells and the reason and what I mean by
that is that there there are almost no
streaming scenarios that you can think
of where wowza is not being used today
from over-the-top scenarios that you see
over in the lore in the lower right
there
two live events two inside enterprises
and universities for surveillance
capabilities as well as sort of planes
trains automobiles and cruise ships for
folks who are putting in their own
on-demand delivery service and and
increasingly not just because they're
going to a fix television mounted to a
wall but because folks and those in the
hospitality business are finding that if
somebody brings their favorite tablet
with them they want to go around the
cruise ship and watch their content no
matter where they are and why is it can
stream to all of them and give folks
that great experience no matter where
they are in that cruise ship is it work
it's also used for we don't really
address it here but it's also used for
things like real-time video conferencing
so a lot of folks have built online
video platforms around that capability
to deliver content and have video chat
and conversations using Wow's of
streaming engine so here is sort of the
market texture slide for how wiles it
works and in one side you see in the
upper left the input and publishing and
what is showing is that we can take an
input from almost any source whether it
be a camera that can put out an IP
stream an IP camera or a network camera
whether it be content that you're
pulling from a drive somewhere say
Google storage whether it's internet
radio or even just you know and you can
pick up an iPhone and run a free app
that will provide you cold while is a go
counter on it and you can hold up and
point it at something that's happening
it's exciting and you can stream it out
to the world
and we can do that from almost any
encoder just because we support so many
incoming protocols so once it gets to
Wow as a streaming engine which is just
a piece
of software that runs either on-premises
or in the cloud and what we really want
to talk today about is the cloud and how
it runs very well on Google compute
engine once we get it we can take that
one stream coming in and typically what
we recommend is people send us one HD
stream if it's a live event and we will
take it and we can transcode it and
translate it which means we can take in
one HD stream and then make different
incremental streams that can be used for
what's called adaptive streaming so if
you've ever watched Netflix or Hulu and
notice that every once in a while even
get a little fuzzy and then will snap
back and be sharp again but you never
see the word buffering it's because a
few years ago adaptive streaming came on
to the market about 2008 and it allows
you to your your player to automatically
adjust as your bandwidth adjusts or as
the what's you're doing on your device
changes you know maybe you've got more
load going and you're in your CPUs
getting bogged down a little bit it'll
adjust to a lower stream one that's
easier for it to playback or to pull
across the network and it will allow you
to play back with a seamless experience
where maybe you just get a little bit of
fuzziness for a couple of seconds but it
keeps on going you don't have to wait
for a buffering symbol and so that's
what adaptive bitrate streaming is all
about and while the streaming engine
allows you to bring in a single stream
and create these multiple streams needed
for adaptive bitrate streaming and
that's it's probably the most popular
use today although it's still really
used a lot for both rtmp traditionally
flash streaming and RTSP streaming which
is an even older version of streaming a
traditional stateful streaming protocol
used by many legacy devices especially
in emerging markets now and then when it
goes out as I mentioned it can go out in
many different streaming formats and it
can go to almost any player you can pick
a player you can send it to a built-in
player on an iPhone or an Android device
you can pick a player like JW player or
Flo player that plays back almost across
any device in any screen it makes it
even simpler because they help you
customize the player and everything so
that you have this really great
experience that's customized for your
content and your delivery for your end
users other things that we can do just
in case it's interesting to you we can
also do things like closed captioning
kind of a key requirement for the FCC
these days
lots of API extensibility here so
anything that you can do through the UI
or through the command line you can also
do directly through the API so you can
actually build this into an offering
that you have completely transparent to
your end-user that you're using this
product and deliver the content to them
and then we have a couple of other
things that used to be called premium
add-ons now they're just part of the
base price of the the product which is
$65 a month for the software I mentioned
the transcoding earlier that capability
to bring in the content not only split
it up into different bit rates but also
bring in content that maybe was encoded
on an older encoder changed the codec
the way it's compressed and then spit it
out as multiple versions and in multiple
formats we also have drm capabilities so
obviously for a lot of you if you're
delivering studio content you need to
have that content protected all the way
across so while the streaming engine can
take in protected content unprotected
decrypt it and then send it out to all
those different devices in multiple
formats encrypted and protected in
multiple ways and we have built in
integration with 3 DRM service providers
and it also works across some some very
wide D rim platforms if you want to do a
little work on your own and then the
last thing is network DVR in DB are that
capability to pause a live stream or
jump ahead or jump back in the stream
that you get and have been able to get
for a number of years with set-top boxes
and TiVo alright so a typical workflow
to sort of take what I just showed you
there is for a live event anyways you
have some kind of camera you have some
live event maybe have multiple cameras
like we have today they're actually
multiple cameras in the room today
capturing this event and if we were
streaming live and next time I hope
we're streaming live with wowza and
Google you would actually pull in those
multiple streams and you can mix them in
real time in something like you can
either just pull it into a single
encoder or you can bring it into a
encoding products such as Telestream
Wirecast or NewTek TriCaster if you've
heard of those bringing multiple streams
and do live mixing of those streams and
switching shots and putting on overlays
and titles so that was that's probably
what you would do at a venue so a lot of
folks use wow
when they are at a live event a football
game a house of worship service live
concert an event like this even and they
capture this event and then they send
out one single stream that's been
compressed with the h.264 video codec
and AAC audio codec and they'll send
that to a wiles of streaming engine in
the cloud and there will do all that
trans rating the creating of the
multiple bitrate files or streams and
will repackage it into those multiple
formats that I talked about smooth
streaming HLS HD s and then will publish
it and you can actually publish directly
from Google compute engine instances
right to a bunch of end users who are on
their phones whether they happen to be
streaming in emerging markets over these
traditional streaming protocols that I
mentioned rtmp and RTSP or you can
publish directly out to a CDN such as
fastly which does a great job of scaling
out all HTTP types streaming so you get
that great adaptive bitrate streaming
plus you get global scalability and then
you hit any screen that's out there
because there are enough players out
there that will allow you to deliver to
any screen in the world just using one
or two formats such as Apple HLS so why
do we use Google we actually started
using Google I'm gonna jump ahead week
we started using Google two years ago
because we saw some things in Google
cloud platform that we were not seeing
with some other cloud providers that
we've been testing on the first thing is
that the startup speed was much faster
this is but you know this is to some
extent this is a lot of anecdotal as
opposed to performance testing but our
engineers realize that the startup speed
was about twice as fast as what we were
getting on other platforms from a
storage performance perspective the i/o
was much better we were able to move
data in and off in in and out of drives
and and on disk and back very quickly
which can be really critical if you're
pulling in a live stream and recording
it in live time and in real time and
then delivering it out especially with
that network DVR capability and then you
want to pull it out later so that you
can have this archive file that you
playback on demand we also found that
with some cloud platforms we've been
using customers were finding
their experience was inconsistent so
they would be they would be running our
server on a cloud platform and they
would find that it would not always be a
consistent behavior and sometimes they
might be able to support 500 concurrent
connections and other times it was a
thousand and it seemed to be a bandwidth
limitation where perhaps too many people
were sharing the same network pipe we
don't see those problems at all with
Google cloud and then from a pricing
perspective it was attractive not only
for us but for our customers who are
just running while the streaming engine
on Google because they could not only as
it was mentioned earlier now and you get
the sustained use pricing where the
longer you use it the more the pricing
drops but also for those folks who are
running sort of the short term events of
the bursty traffic and they wanted to be
able to just pay for what they use the
23 minutes not the full hour and the
final thing that we like is that when
we're creating an image we don't have to
create an image for each region as you
might have to do on some other platforms
made it very easy we create a single
image we populate it out there put it in
a storage bucket and everyone can get to
it we don't have to create multiple
versions of just specific for a region
so what's coming next I'm showing here
on one side the steps that it takes to
get started with wiles of streaming
engine on google compute and it's not
that very it's not very difficult right
it's the number of steps that you have
to go through but if you want to do this
on a regular basis this might get a
little bit you might get a little
tedious if you had to do it all the time
and with multiple instances so there's
certainly a much easier way to do it and
that's using click to deploy so we'll be
able to soon I'm hoping that we're going
to be able to offer the first commercial
click to the ploy offering today if you
go to the Google cloud site you will
find that they're a bunch of click to
deploy offerings out there all open
source where you can go and very quickly
click on an offering and it'd take a
couple of make a couple of configuration
settings and then launch it and it just
saves a whole lot of steps in
configuration and we're going to be
offering that you'll also be able very
soon to start doing things where you
take a whole bunch of resources in a
similar way you can say I want to fire
up three instances I want to use this
storage I want to push it to fastly and
you can do it all through essentially
one configuration script you'll be able
to do that very soon too so that once
you have your settings the way you want
them you can just fire it off the same
way every time
speaking of fastly we're also going to
be offering fastly integration soon so
today you can do it there are a few
steps involved we're gonna make it a lot
easier the simple way is you there are
two ways you can do it really the first
way is if you have a live stream you can
push it to a storage bucket makes it
very easy and then fastly just picks it
up from there and distributes globally
we also have very low latency
connections because fastly is co-located
where or has the interconnects where
Google cloud platform is located so the
the connections there are really low
latency which is very good for us as far
as getting content to your users faster
so the TV they don't hear the cheer on
the TV you know several seconds before
they see it on their device and then the
last thing is if you're doing on-demand
streaming and you're pulling the content
off of a Google compute engine instance
using fastly as your distribution
mechanism as Simon mentioned earlier
they have the origin shield capability
which protects the origin from getting
too many requests at once from all those
edge nodes that vastly wrongs they just
have a single request come back all the
time and then feed all those nodes and
so that workflow that I showed you
earlier would look like this when you
put fastly in the middle so that's it if
you have questions we'll have Q&A later
I'll be happy to answer them and first
I'll stick around also as well if you
have other questions or feel free to
email